in 2013 May and bik's personal life
experienced a major upheaval when she
and Michael Stone divorced after 10
years of marriage for biik the end of
her marriage also brought up difficult
emotions while she was filming the
season 11 finale in which Amy and
Sheldon tie the knot Amy may have been
bursting with excitement but behind the
scenes biic was uncomfortable I tried to
be married once like I was in that
position and I failed despite these
feelings biic still went through with
the episode and it's possible her
onscreen marriage helped biic move past
her sense of failure because a few years
later she began dating her current
boyfriend Jonathan Cohan